dan just said he's giving 500 bucks to
the next person ask a question also man
congrats Dan I'm waiting for that but um
I don't what you know a craig costs like
a conde nast how are you hey Craig how
are you um quick question so yeah what
you just mentioned I it's really
interesting writes the idea that you
know somebody can see the kind of direct
results that my content has no green
mountain coffee they can get cups so for
a larger purchase item right where think
about autos for instance yeah it's like
average like you use 8 to 10 different
sources to actually buy your product and
you're only making that product purchase
once every couple years for a higher
ticket item how do you how to use an
attribution model right to kind of go
back to are you actually getting lead
gen are you actually move sure vehicles
so this is like the most interesting
question for me in the whole space
especially around social in the content
within it the answer is you use the same
model used for everything else right
it's an impression somewhere along the
decision-making path right and so a lot
of people come to me and like well
what's the ROI of the social media
content we're producing and then I'm
always asking them cool like awesome and
and this was a real question for me
asking them because I was just getting
into the industry I'm like well how do
you do it for outdoor media how do you
do it for your print how are you doing
it for your commercials and the answers
were straight garbage [ __ ] right I
started like calling my you know nerd
[ __ ] friends at MIT and they're like
this is [ __ ] math I'm like right and so
like you know so the funny thing is is I
continue to try to figure out when they
asked me that question why they don't
have an answer for any of the
traditional [ __ ] other than [ __ ]
Nielsen's told them you know is it's you
know it hurts right you know you like
like the math that i I've a national I
have a big television client and they
are spending so much money on outdoor
media right and I'm like cool i'm like
by the way as you're debating my scope
over here for this [ __ ] nothing money
that you put in one [ __ ] billboard in
Kansas can you explain to me what the
ROI that billboard is and nobody's ever
got an answer there's models there's
things that our industry has accepted
you know your company in the print
business we've expect the accepted three
times circulation when I finally learned
a couple months ago what that meant was
Oh Jane might leave her [ __ ] vogue in
a bus and I might come up pick it up and
go to page 14
7 and see the [ __ ] Jaguar ad right I
was like [ __ ] that's [ __ ] up right
right aight respect good brand right so
you know i mean i think that a lot of
things have been except in this world
and it's funny you know now that i'm not
in my wine shop which is over there in
New Jersey every time I come once every
2-3 months everything's broken when I
was in it it all seemed right I'd been
in at my whole life you know I I was so
successful but it's like [ __ ] with a new
I it's like so many things are flawed
the things I've learned from other areas
I feel like I walk around in this world
and I'm like wow how like wow right you
know you come with fresh eyes I think
that there's a lot of [ __ ] that is being
accepted that is not true I mean you
know some dudes stood at the top of that
building clicked how many cars drove i
multiplied it and came up with a price
for the billboard that's on you know the
second it's ridiculous you know as I
told that client and I'd like to say in
keynotes and some of you've seen this um
you know when you drop when you you know
we're in New York so you know a lot of
you might be from the west coast when
your home when you drive the next time
watch how many people out of the five
people you drive past or on their cell
phone while they're driving at least
three of the five at least so I always
tell my clients I'm like people are
looking at billboard's they're not even
looking at the [ __ ] road anymore and
so I think it's every person in this
room's job to care about one thing where
are the eyes and ears of the end
consumer and the eyes and ears are
shifting that last panel they're clearly
in mobile but very honestly I've been
like obsessed with mobile for the last
three years it's all I think about most
of things I investin try to figure out
how to storytelling it but now very
honestly after playing around with
google glasses I'm like [ __ ] I'm like
all right now this right and so like
what's going to happen when somebody
goes into a supermarket and my clients
product has some bad news on it and when
they look at it it's physically going to
be there and giving them information
about the recall or why it's not healthy
I mean you know it's we're not going to
need McDonald's to put the calories on
the sign we're gonna get it if we want
it based on the app's we put on our
Google glasses and that's 36 months away
it's gonna be here in a heartbeat so at
the end of the day we can talk about
tactics in here all we want and we
should be executing because it matters
but I think there's a philosophy ship
that
needs to happen overall which is we have
to start from the consumer not from us I
think there's way too much us talk and
us think what we want what's good for us
this will be good for us if this happens
if you reverse engineer what they want
you have a far better chance of the
conversion that we're all looking for